i'm trying to keep the anger down so
i've been like meditating
you've been meditating you seem like a
very angry guy i uh
i can't believe i get i can't even
imagine you meditating yeah
i get angry at the guy's voice because
every time i start getting there
he'll just start going like just let
thoughts go don't think anything it's
like i wasn't
and then you started talking and then i
get mad at him and he literally becomes
this thing i have to try and block out
um i don't know are you like i mean okay
so you're trying to be
because you want to be calm i don't want
my kid to ever see me yelling
i grew up with that i don't want her to
see that thing so like i have like these
different techniques i do
i do a lot of walking away now like me
and my wife i think it should be this
way i think through that way then i feel
like the volcano coming up and i just
literally
just do like exit stage right i just
walk into another room
i just stand and they're like this isn't
worth it i get i don't i don't even know
what i'm angry at anymore
yeah i get angry over nothing it's just
all
crap from like you know you know what
the deal is you grow up and you take
your childhood out on people
at some point you got to stop so trying
to do that i've been
i turned that into a show i uh oh i
don't know what you're talking about
this is that's genius this is yeah this
is that is genius
thank you ma thank you that's how you do
it
all right but i'm sure i just cannot
believe you're go your child is going to
see you lose it
bill there's no way you're going to lose
it you're going to meditate you're going
to do whatever
in that parent thing it's not going to
happen it's going to be horrible
she's going to be in the car with you
what do you like in the car
driving around i'm much better how much
it depends on what you if you make an
aggressive move
i don't get mad at aggression i get like
that willy-nilly
can i turn here what do i do that's when
i'm just like go
i start screaming but like if you make
you know you pass me on the grass
if you make it i mean i i can't get mad
at that it's like i get it
i i want to do that too i just don't
have to nerf but
just do it fast do it whatever you're
going to do
all right if you're going to hit me
t-bone me get it all right